Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Wochenlang haben wir jetzt schon mit Katrin Scheib gesprochen, immer wieder über die Situation in Russland. Wie erlebt eigentlich dieses Land die Weltmeisterschaft? Und jetzt wollen wir wissen, wie ist es eigentlich während des laufenden Turniers? Jetzt hier im Kurzpass. Katrin, sei mir sehr gegrüßt.
Morgen.
Da werden die Katrin Scheib-Ultras unter den Rasenfunk-Hörern und Hörern wieder jubeln. Endlich wieder eine Folge mit dir.
Endlich eigene Ultras.
Du hast eine große Fangemeinde unter meinen Hörern und Hörern. Was daran liegt, dass wir jetzt schon zum fünften oder sechsten Mal, ich weiß es gerade nicht mehr genau, zum sechsten Mal sprechen wir schon miteinander, wir haben im Dezember angefangen. Und all die Monate über war im Grunde meine Einstiegsfrage immer in abgewandeter Form, hey, wie viel WM-Stimmung ist schon in Russland zu spüren? Und dass da im Dezember sehr wenig war und dass da im Februar wenig war, alles klar. Dann haben wir am WM-Eröffnungstag miteinander gesprochen. Du hast gesagt, immer noch so, boah, also ich war heute Morgen schon auf so einer WM-Entdeckungstour, da war noch nicht so arg viel. Und jetzt stelle ich dir diese Frage noch einmal, Katrin, und ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, die Antwort ist eine komplett andere. Also wie ist gerade die Stimmung in Russland?
Ja, es ist jetzt hier WM-Stimmung. Wir haben gestern, nee, vorgestern überlegt, was Sommermärchen auf Russisch heißt. Es ist ehrlich gesagt, dadurch, dass jetzt ja die Gruppenphase schon vorbei ist, ist es in Moskau schon ein klein bisschen wieder abgeappt. Also natürlich nicht nennenswert, gerade weil die russische Mannschaft so spielt, wie sie spielt und dass die Einheimischen halt total mitreißt. Aber dass sie jeden Abend richtig Remi Demi in der Stadt war, war halt vor allen Dingen in der Gruppenphase, als viele lateinamerikanische Fans noch hier waren, die halt genau so Party machen, wie du dir das vorstellst. Und genau, wir hatten ja da an dem Morgen vom 14. gesprochen, wo mir auch auffiel, dass man im Stadtbild noch ganz vieles nicht sieht. Und das ist so lustig, weil du gehst jetzt halt vorbei und da steht irgendwie, an der Bushaltestelle hab ich neulich gesehen, Brasilien, Qualität auf dem Platz, Qualität bei Hähnchenfleisch. Also, die sind dann eingestiegen auf die WM-Werbung, die sind vielleicht ein bisschen spät dran und ich gehe davon aus, dass das dann über Turnierende noch länger zu sehen ist. Aber nee, also was jetzt so auf den Straßen abends in Moskau angeht, das ist echt total, wie man sich das wünscht. Friedliche, aber jubeltrunkenen und auch sonst natürlich trunkene Fans, große Verbrüderungsszenen, Musik und Gesinge, Autokorso, wenn das Verkehrsaufkommen es zulässt, sonst halt Autokorso im Stau.
Sogar unter Beteiligung von städtischen Bussen habe ich bei dir gesehen.
Genau, ja, das war lustig. Das war nach dem Russland-Spiel mit ein paar Freunden in der Kneipe geguckt und ein Freund und ich haben dann beschlossen, wir fahren jetzt noch in die Innenstadt. Auf die Nikolska, das ist so die eine Straße, die Bilder haben alle gesehen, wo diese Lichter-Deko von oben runter hängen.
Sieht aus wie ein ewiger Adventsmarkt.
Total, das war Weihnachtsdeko und dann irgendwann im April haben sie Schmetterlinge damit reingehängt und plötzlich ist es früh, also das ist dieses Jahr auch neu. Jedenfalls sind wir dahin und die Straße ist ja eine Fußgängerzone, die ist relativ breit, in der Mitte so eine Achse aus Bänken und Blumenpötten und so und das ist wie frohen Leichnamen. Du prozessierst auf der einen Seite hin, machst ein U, prozessierst auf der anderen Seite zurück und winkst dir und bejubelst dich mit allen, an denen du vorbeikommst. Da war ein Typ, der hat Flaggen verkauft, der hat garantiert das Geschäft seines Lebens gemacht, also Russische und es ist halt echt angenehm, freundlich, entspannt. Im Moment ist es echt so, wie man es gerne möchte.
Ich habe dabei Twitter auch gesehen, gerade zu dieser Straße, dass es da wohl Metalldetektoren gab, die die Massen einfach auf die Seite geschoben haben. Das war so ein Indiz dafür, wie viele Dinge gerade in Russland passieren, die sonst nicht passieren würden. Warum? Also habe ich das richtig verstanden? Stehen da sonst Metalldetektoren am Eingang dieser Straße oder wie war das gemeint?
Nicht normalerweise, also bei großen Veranstaltungen. Wenn zum Beispiel es gibt zum Beispiel im Herbst ein großes Musikfestival, Militärmusikfestival auf einem guten Platz und dann machen die halt Einlass über solche Dinge. Also das ist nur bei Großveranstaltungen, wenn du da Menschenmassen hast. Das ist dann halt genau dieses, also sind diese Bögen, wo du durchgehst, musst einmal deine Tasche aufmachen und so. Das ist jetzt nicht anders als in anderen Ländern, wo du bei Großveranstaltungen Sicherheitskontrollen hast, also richtig auf öffentlichen Plätzen. Ich habe das selbst nicht mitgekriegt, dass die Leute, die da weggeschoben haben. Ich habe es aber auch von verschiedenen Leuten gehört, die da waren. Ich habe keinen Grund, das anzuzweifeln. Und das stimmt total. Also viele Russen erleben gerade mit, weiß ich nicht, Verwunderung, Amüsement, manchmal auch ein bisschen konsterniert, was hier gerade möglich ist und was Leute dürfen, wenn plötzlich WM ist. Das fängt ja an mit ganz banalen Sachen wie transparent ausrollen oder in einer Gruppe von Menschen gemeinsam irgendwo hinlaufen, was ja alles schon unangemeldete Demos sind und für einen Russen abseits der WM halt unerfreuliche Folgen haben kann. Und plötzlich geht das alles. Leute klettern auf einer Ternmaske und werden nicht runtergescheucht. Der Andrew Roth, der hier für den Guardian ist, hat eine tolle Reportage geschrieben über diesen Abend nach dem Russland-Sieg, wo er schrieb, habt ihr auch den Betrunkenen gesehen, der einen Polizisten mit so viel Liebe umarmt hat, dass sie beide vor Schwung umgefallen sind. Also sowas geht plötzlich. Und es liegt halt die Frage in der Luft, wie lange das geht. Also endet das, sagen wir mal, am 16. Juli, Tag nach dem Endspiel? Oder hat das einen Einfluss, dass Leute sagen, Moment, ich habe jetzt gesehen, was in meinem Land geht. Ich werde das noch mehr einfordern. Andererseits, es lag ja auch vorher nicht daran, dass Leute nicht demonstrieren gegangen sind oder so. Es hat nichts an den sehr eingeschränkten Versammlungsrechten geändert. Es gibt ein Video, was hier so die Runde macht, wo ein Typ abends zwei Polizisten anspricht und sagt, hör mal, hier kann ich denn dann eigentlich jetzt auch in Zukunft auf der Straße Alkohol trinken? Dann sagen die, was bist du von Hause aus? Was für eine Nationalität? Dann sagt der, ja, Russe. Dann sagt der, nee, dann nicht. Also für die Ausländer wird ja inzwischen offenbar alles erlaubt, aber für die Russen gelten russische Regeln. Und das mag geflaxt gewesen sein, aber das zeigt schon, wie die Debatte läuft.
Ja, wäre es nicht auch irgendwie verwunderlich, ohne dass ich jetzt Schmerzwahlen will, aber dass es danach nicht wieder in den Status Quo zurückrücken würde, denn dieser sehr etwas repressive Status Quo, der hat ja seinen Grund. Also das scheint ja anscheinend ein Mittel zu sein, um die Bevölkerung insofern linientreu zu halten, vielleicht auch, dass dieses riesige Land regierbar ist. Ich weiß nicht, ich will es jetzt nicht damit rechtfertigen, aber es gibt ja einen Grund, dass es vor der WM so war, wie es war. Und dann wäre es doch wahrscheinlicher, dass dieser kurze Ausnahmezustand dazu keinerlei Veränderungen führt, oder?
Also natürlich ist das das Plausibelste. Du wirst jetzt nicht sehen, es wird jetzt nicht nach WM-Ende irgendwie die große Erkenntnis geben, ach schau mal, wir sollten wirklich mehr Versammlungsfreiheit haben. Es wäre ja naiv zu vermuten, dass in der Regierung sich da irgendein Umdenken ein anderer Ansatz bereit macht. Die Frage ist mehr so, ob das manchmal so ein Samenkorn ist, ob da in manchen Köpfen noch mehr gärt. Ich habe jetzt halt gesehen, dass es in meinem Land geht. Und jetzt frage ich mich, warum geht es nur, wenn die Welt auf uns guckt. Und warum geht es nicht in vier Wochen, in vier Monaten, in vier Jahren, wenn sich im Ausland wieder weniger Leute für das Leben in Russland interessieren? Ich glaube, dass es bei manchen Leuten politisiert ist. Aber dass es vielleicht noch mal so ein Denkanstoß ist für viele Leute, die vielleicht bis jetzt über sowas noch nicht nachgedacht haben. Das kann ich mir schon vorstellen.
Und wie würdest du dir dann da die Berichterstattung drüber wünschen? Mir fällt auf, dass es sehr, sehr viele positive Berichterstattungen gibt. Und die kritischen Töne haben im Grunde, so wie es fast immer bei Fußballturnieren ist, mit dem ersten Anpfiff eines Spiels so ein bisschen aufgehört. Und auf der einen Seite ist das auch verständlich. Man will ja auch nicht die ganze Zeit immer diese Aber-Sätze bringen. Also jetzt gerade ist die Stimmung gut, aber erinnern wir uns, wie es sonst immer ist. Alles ganz, ganz fürchterlich. Und man will ja auch nicht immer das immer gleiche Russland-Bild transportieren. Gerade hier in Deutschland ist das ja auch ein sehr vorgefertigtes inzwischen in der aktuellen Medienberichterstattung. Trotzdem ist es ja irgendwie Teil dessen, dass man eben schon sagt, naja, also bei allen schönen Bildern, die man da sieht, muss man schon auch wissen, so ist es hier nicht immer. Und zwar ganz im Gegenteil. Du kannst hier normalerweise keinen Transparent enthüllen, ohne dass dir Probleme drohen als Einzelperson. Wie wäre da in deiner Meinung nach der richtige Mix? Oder wird da gerade vielleicht schon gefunden?
Also ich finde tatsächlich, man sieht einiges an Berichterstattung, wo durchaus, also zum Beispiel die ganze Sache, mit Kadirov und Musalla, dass sich da jemand einladen lässt, um mit einem Menschen, da gibt es kein anderes Wort für, mit einem Gewaltherrscher, da zu tafeln. Und da mit dem natürlich ohne Ende PR-Material in seiner eigenen Heimat, vor seiner eigenen Bevölkerung zu liefern, da lässt sich jemand instrumentalisieren. Und ich fand, das war wichtig, dass das thematisiert worden ist, da habe ich gute Berichterstattung zugesehen. Und das negiert ja auch nicht die ganze positive, freudige, fußballverliebte Berichterstattung. Das ist immer so ein unfassbar schlichtes Weltbild, wenn Leute glauben, es kann nur eins von beiden geben. Ein Land, in dem Menschen mit Freude leben. Und ein Land, das seine Bürger unterdrückt in vielen Bereichen ihres Lebens, ihnen wenig Freiheiten zugesteht und sie verfolgt, wenn sie aufmucken. Als gäbe es nicht auch in einem solchen System Freude an so vielen Dingen. Natürlich ist es dann oft die Abkehr ins Private. Meine Freunde, meine Familie, mein kleines Wochenende auf der Datsche. Aber was ist das für ein schlichtes Weltbild, wenn Leute glauben, es gäbe nur eins von beiden?
Nur weil es WM ist, ist es jetzt nicht so, dass vorher ein in Graustufen gezeichnetes Russland auf einmal Farbe hätte und die WM ist weg.
Ich glaube, die Graustufen sind genau das Problem, weil halt weiterhin durch aus geschichtlichen Gründen, aus praktischen Gründen wie so einem Tamtam so viele Leute hier noch nicht waren. Das heißt, die stellen sich hier sowas Sowjetisches vor und die Menschen müssen um rot anstehen und verhärmte Gesichter auf der Straße. Und wenn es irgendwo mal Bananen geht, dann stehen alle an. Und dabei, wenn du in Moskau bist, und da gibt es halt inzwischen, wenn du das ausreichende Geld hast, was die wenigsten haben, aber theoretisch gibt es halt alles. Du kannst hier das ganze Jahr frische Erdbeeren kaufen, wenn du möchtest. Und du kannst natürlich in irgendwelchen geilen Rooftop-Bars dein Sushi essen. Aber was sagt es denn aus? Nur weil es sich vielleicht ein bisschen anfühlt, wie etwas, was vertraut ist, Kapitalismus, Konsum, Werbung, die blinkt, heißt das ja noch nicht, dass das politische System ist, wie man es kennt. Wenn du fragst, was ich mir für eine Berichterstattung wünsche, ich wünsche mir eine, die diesen Sushi bald weiter aufgreift. Nicht wie so ein Disclaimer. Russland hat Spanien geschlagen. Es wird immer noch verhindert, dass Nawalny bei irgendwelchen Wahlen antritt. Das wäre ja Hanebüchen. Aber es gibt eben beide Arten von Berichterstattung. Da wünsche ich mir von den ganzen Leuten, die jetzt auf Russland gucken und sagen, schau mal, so ein Russland-Bild, das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht. Ist super, dass ihr das nicht gedacht habt. Schön, dass ihr euch damit auseinandersetzt. Aber vielleicht interessiert euch dieses Land ja auch über dieses Turnier hinaus. Und vielleicht interessiert ihr euch auch mal für politische Berichterstattung. Also, so wie wir eben darüber gesprochen haben, was könnte es mit den Russen machen, wenn dieses Turnier vorbei ist, würde mich auch interessieren. Was macht es denn so mit der Welt und ihre Interesse an Russland abseits von das ist böse oder das ist nicht böse, also so Kindertankschemata. Also wenn die Leute da Bock hätten auf ein bisschen Komplexität und Differenzierung, dann fände ich das ganz gut, wenn sie sich weiter über Russland informieren.
Ja, vor allem weißt du, welchen Gedanken ich jetzt sehr häufig hatte in den letzten zwei Wochen? Also ich denke auch sehr viel drüber nach, wie man über Russland spricht. Und es wurde mir auch unter anderem vorgeworfen auf YouTube von einigen Kommentatoren, dass ich da ein vorgefertigtes Russland-Bild verfolgen würde, was so in den deutschen Medien sehr präsent ist. Also da ist Russland immer erst mal das Böse, das Unheimliche. Natürlich war Russland das mit Skripal, da müssen wir gar nicht die Beweise abwarten. Huch, ach Moment, auch andere hatten diesen Bürgstoff. Na ja, es deutet trotzdem alles auf Russland hin. Also immer so sehr tendentiös. Das kann man schon so beobachten. Und da habe ich auch viel drüber nachgedacht, weil ich eigentlich gar kein solches Russland-Bild vertrete und mich auch gewundert habe, waren auch nur einzelne Kommentatoren. Aber das Gefühl, was ich jetzt hatte, während der WM die ganze Zeit, war eigentlich dieser Klassiker, dass wenn du über Länder sprichst, dann sprichst du in der normalen Berichterstattung über Politik und über politische Dinge. Und dazu gibt es dann immer auch Bewertungen aus dem eigenen Wertekontext. Also sprich, etwas ist schon mal anders politisch, als es hier in Deutschland ist. Dann ist es schon mal irgendwie komisch und im Zweifel auch eher schlechter, weil wir sind ja so toll hier in Deutschland. Bei uns ist ja alles so demokratisch und freiheitsrechtlich und so weiter und so fort. Außer Internet, da haben wir es nicht so drauf. Aber worum es nie geht oder ganz, ganz selten sind eigentlich die Menschen. Und du bekommst auch sehr wenig von den Menschen mit, jenseits von irgendwelchen Straßenumfragen, die bei weitem nicht repräsentativ sind. Wo du auch manchmal den Eindruck hast, da haben jetzt die Redakteure und Redakteurinnen nur die O-Töne genommen, die zur Geschichte passen. Und es gibt es ganz selten, dass man mal wirklich das Gefühl hat, man lernt jetzt ein bisschen die Menschen eines Landes kennen. Also mir ist das zum Beispiel aufgefallen, rund um die Wahl von Donald Trump, wo dann über seine Wähler gelästert wurde, die in Schubladen gesteckt wurden, und man den Eindruck hatte, mein Gott, das müssen ja die schlimmsten Menschen dieses Planeten sein. Und dann fährt Markus Lanz in den Rust Belt und unterhält sich da mit Leuten und man merkt, ach du Scheiße, wenn ich in deren Situation wäre und deren Horizont hätte, ich glaube, ich kann zumindest nachvollziehen, wie man zur Entscheidung kommt, jemanden zu wählen, der sonst in ganz vielen Dingen gegen alles steht, für das wir sonst sind. Und diesen Eindruck habe ich jetzt bei der russischen Bevölkerung auch, dass man einfach gar nicht so sehr über Dokus, da gab es jetzt gar nicht so viele im deutschen Fernsehen, aber man hat das Gefühl, irgendwie man käme der russischen Bevölkerung näher. Und es geht jetzt nicht mehr die ganze Zeit nur um Putin und um Mutko und um die ganzen großen politischen Themen, sondern um die ganzen kleinen Themen, nämlich um russische Menschen, die Leute, die in Russland leben, die fröhlich sind. Und das hebt das Ganze gleich auf eine ganz andere Ebene, finde ich.
Ja, das teile ich so halb, ehrlich gesagt. Also ich verstehe, dass man jetzt mehr über Alltag, über Fußballfans und so erfährt, das ist sicherlich so. Ich glaube, dass das Bild, was du zeichnest von der medialen Berichterstattung, sehr viel natürlich mit nachrichtlicher Berichterstattung zu tun hat. Weil natürlich, da berichtest du eben über politische Zusammenhänge, über Außenpolitik, Innenpolitik, die Wirtschaft im Lande. Und natürlich ist es ein absoluter Fakt, dass du hier in Russland sehr viel weniger Freiheiten hast als in einem Land wie Deutschland. Das ist ein Fakt. Und das wird nicht negiert durch eine schöne WM, sondern das kann beides existieren. Der Knackpunkt ist halt, die nachrichtliche Berichterstattung, die wird dir begegnen, ob du sie suchst oder nicht. Weil die läuft zur vollen und halben Stunde im Radio, die kommt abends in der Tagesschau, die begegnet dir im Internet, weil das sind die Schlagzeilen. Ich teile nicht so ganz deine Einschätzung, dass es die Geschichten über die Menschen und den Alltag nicht gibt. Die muss man aber eben finden wollen, weißt du? Und da finde ich zum Beispiel, da ist Twitter ein super Tool, weil dann folgt eben nicht nur den News-Accounts, sondern folgt den Reportern, die hier im Land unterwegs sind. Weiß ich nicht. Die Kolinär-Atei hat eine Doku gemacht über eine Russin, die durch Russland reist und Frauen, die Opfer von häuslicher Gewalt geworden sind, über die Wunden, die sie davon haben, Tattoos macht. Was ist denn das für eine Geschichte? Was für eine tolle Geschichte? Und trist da ganz viele normale Menschen. Das ist keine politische Geschichte, sondern das ist eine menschliche Geschichte. Und natürlich hat das einen Bruchteil der Zuschauer, die eine Tagesschau hat. Aber dann, wenn man eben den Anspruch hat, ein differenziertes Bild von einem Land zu haben, dann muss man eben auch nach so was gucken und darf nicht warten, bis es an einer großen Person wie Markus Lanz hängt, um da eine Analogie zu machen. Dass der einem so etwas sichtbar macht. Also da ist man durchaus auch in der Pflicht, sich selbst zu informieren.
Ja, was man aber, glaube ich, nicht von allen Leuten leider erwarten kann. Aber ich gebe dir das schon recht. Also es gibt definitiv auch den anderen Blick. Und da gibt es auch andere Wege. Aber es ist letztlich so eine innere, äußere Mainstream-Diskussion. Das ist jetzt ein Fachbegriff. Wer den aufwachen Podcast hört, der wird ihn verstehen. Geht jetzt vielleicht zu sehr ins Medien-Theoretische. Aber ich wollte dich gar nicht unterbrechen.
Also die Kurzpassung ist, glaube ich, einfach, es ist nicht so schwer, sich auch aufgrund normaler, medialer Berichterstattung ein fundiertes Russland-Bild zu machen. Aber man darf dann eben nicht sich auf 15 Minuten Tagesschau am Tag verlassen. Und wie gesagt, ich finde Twitter ist super auch, weil man dann eben zum Beispiel sieht, Menschen in Russland sind eben nicht nur Fußballfans, sondern du kannst eben genauso gut auch dort den Menschen begegnen, die in irgendeiner Stadt sind und sich wundern, was ich eben gesagt habe, warum dürfen die schwedischen Fans hier im Rudel, im gleichen Trikot durch die Stadt ziehen? Warum darf ich das eigentlich nicht? Warum darf ich nicht mit zwei meiner Freunden mir das gleiche T-Shirt anziehen, ohne dass wir ärger mit der Polizei kriegen?
Ist das wirklich so, dass das jetzt ein überzeichnetes Bild ist? Also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel ein Eishockeyspiel bei dem Russland-Spiel wäre, dann darf ich das schon.
Nein, das ist natürlich unpolitisch, aber das ist, wenn du jetzt hier als Fan rumläufst. Aber sobald du ein T-Shirt, das irgendwie...
Also ein Junggesellen-Abschied, wo nicht klar ist, was soll das Motiv drauf sein, auf den Motto T-Shirts könnte schon, da kriegt man dann schon eine Frage gestellt. Warum haben hier sechs Leute...
Also, ich glaube, ein Junggesellen-Abschied, da kennst du absolut 100 Meter gegen den Wind, auch schon an der Fahne. Nein, aber du weißt, was ich meine. Sobald da irgendeine Absicht hintersteckt, wird es dir passieren, dass du mindestens mal angesprochen wirst und dich erklären musst und vielleicht auch mehr. Und das ist auch das beschäftigt, Leute. Auch das kannst du bei Twitter nachlesen. Also, da gab es ja sehr schöne Tweets gerade zu Beginn, wo Leute geschrieben haben, guck mal, das Gefühl, wenn Leute in dein Land kommen und die haben plötzlich mehr Rechte als du. Und auch so ein Bild, das ist ja durchaus ein differenzierteres. Und es hat mal am Rande mit Fußball zu tun. Auch das kannst du kriegen, wenn du dich bei Twitter bewegst, finde ich. Mal ein paar Leute folgst, die aus dem Land berichten, in dem Land auch sind und so was retweeten. Also das finde ich ist ein super, aber es ist halt Arbeit. Also, sich informieren, über Schlagzeilen hinaus ist Arbeit, klar.
Da gab es ja auch einige Dinge, die jetzt passiert sind, bei dieser WM, die absolut außerordentlich waren. Am Rand zwischen bitter und irgendwie doch lustig fand ich, dass Slutsky, der ehemalige Trainer der russischen Nationalmannschaft, das getan hat, was niemand tun sollte im russischen Staatsfernsehen, nämlich den Namen des größten Putin-Kritikers aktuell zu nennen.
Also der Nachname von Nawalny, muss man sagen, ist auch ein Attraktiv. Und der Moderator hatte das verwendet, aber halt nicht um Nawalny zu sagen, sondern um etwas zu beschreiben, was fußballisch ist. Und dann daraufhin hat Slutsky eigentlich nur so zurückgepflanzt, ha ha ha, Nawalny, ja, bist du mal mal schauen, wie der eigentlich Fußball spielt oder so. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was der genaue Satz war. Und es gab natürlich sofort Wellen von Leuten, das konnte man online mitlesen, und großer Spaß, weil eben in den öffentlichen, in den staatlichen Medien hier, die die allermeisten Fernsehkanäle nun mal sind, entweder Unruh, du warst staatlich, oder irgendwelche Staatenunternehmen oder so, die Strategie ist, nicht mal mehr ignorieren, um es mal auf Berlinerisch zu sagen. Also wir erwähnen einfach nicht den Namen, wir berichten möglichst wenig über den, dann wissen möglichst wenig Leute, dass den gibt, und klar, der baut sich über YouTube seine Gegenöffentlichkeit auf, aber das ist natürlich in der Nische. Und plötzlich sagt einer, zu einer super Sendezeit auf dem wahrscheinlich populärsten Fernsehsender in Russland, Nawalny. Und es geht total ab. Und Leute reden schon drüber, was Sludzki als nächstes sagen könnte. Zum Beispiel das Referendum auf der Krim, das war ja auch nicht so sauber. Oder ob wir demnächst alle noch Rente kriegen oder nicht. Also die ganzen heißen politischen Themen. Ja, und die nächste Info ist dann auch das Sludzki nichts weiteres mehr. Also für keine weiteren Sendungen als Experte zur Verfügung stehen wird. Und ich weiß nicht mal, ob das eine Konsequenz war oder nicht. Es gab hinterher auch Leute, die gesagt haben, der hat das vorher angekündigt, der macht das nur für kurze Zeit. Und dann muss er wieder zurück nach Europa, wo er ja, ich glaube, Vitesse trainiert. Also natürlich, wie in den meisten Fällen, weißt du nicht, ist das korreliert oder ist es nur ein Zusammenhang oder findet es nur zufällig gleichzeitig statt. Aber es hätte mich so oder so schon sehr gewundert, wenn er danach noch mal irgendwo Experte gewesen wäre, während dieser WM.
Was mir da aufgefallen ist, das war eins von vielen Beispielen, das habe ich jetzt natürlich auch wieder aus deinem ausgezeichneten Blog auf karscheib.de, da können alle Hörerinnen und Hörer gerne mal draufgucken. Das ist eins von vielen Beispielen, was du genannt hast, wo ein Teil der russischen Öffentlichkeit sehr humorvoll mit etwas umgegangen ist. Und meinem Eindruck nach war der wesentliche Kanal, um diesen Humor zu teilen, Twitter. Ist das jetzt, täuscht das nur, weil wir zwei auch sehr aktiv auf Twitter sind? Oder ist das wirklich ein wichtiges soziales Netzwerk? Und hat man denn da auch nichts zu befürchten, wenn man da solche Krimwitze zum Beispiel macht?
Also Twitter ist wichtig, aber ich würde mal so 30 Prozent Verzerrung dafür rausrechnen, dass es halt das ist, wo ich mich auch am meisten bewege, wo ich also am wahrscheinlichsten irgendwelche Stimmen sehe. Also da gibt es sicherlich noch andere Sachen. Also gerade auf Kontakt ist es natürlich total groß, wo immer alle sagen, das russische Facebook, also ist so die Analogie. Da bin ich aber nicht besonders aktiv. Das heißt, wenn ich dann irgendwie Stimmen zusammenstelle zu dem Thema, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit einfach auch größer, dass sie von Twitter sind. Ich weiß nicht, wie sehr das was aussagt über die Relevanz von Twitter. Und jetzt weiß ich dann die zweite Frage nicht mehr.
Hat man etwas zu befürchten, wenn man so öffentlich kritisch ist?
Also, auf dem Niveau einmal ein Witz gemacht und jetzt gerade auch wieder während der WM, wo alle gucken, halte ich es für eher unwahrscheinlich. Es hat mir so auch noch nicht begegnet, aber es ist auch nicht komplett ausgeschlossen. Wir haben bei CODA so eine Reihe mal gehabt, oder die läuft sogar noch, Jail for a Like, wo es eben genau darum geht, wo Leute für ihr Verhalten bei Social Media ein Problem mit der Polizei, mit den Gerichten bekommen haben, und jetzt nicht die Baustellen, die wir in Deutschland kennen, Bedrohung, üble Nachrede, Volksverhetzung, sondern die haben eben die Annexion der Krim kritisiert, oder den Krieg in Syrien, die russische Beteiligung da. Das ist zum Teil auch einfach nicht vorhersehbar, weil vieles hier in diesem Land darauf basiert, es ist nicht so, du hast ein klares Gesetz, und das sagt dann, tue A, dann geschieht B, und tue C, dann geschieht D, sondern das ist ja eine Strategie, vieles im Unklaren zu lassen, darf man es, darf man es nicht, hat es Konsequenzen, hat es keine, weil allein das schon reicht in vielen Fällen, um Leute zögern zu lassen, sage ich das jetzt, sage ich das nicht, schreibe ich das jetzt, schreibe ich das nicht. Das ist ja eine sehr bewusste, sehr gezielte Strategie, diese Unklarheit.
Ja klar, dass man so ein bisschen offen ist. Das hat mich nur interessiert, weil ich da schon viel im Nichtrasen-Funk-Kontext mit Leuten darüber gesprochen habe, über den Einsatz von Twitter in der Türkei und andere Themen. Deswegen wollte ich da mal nachfragen.
Also ganz kurz nur zum Beispiel Nawalny ist da natürlich, also wie gesagt, das Stichwort Gegenöffentlichkeit, für den sind soziale Netzwerke natürlich super wichtig. Also das siehst du bei Twitter, das siehst du bei YouTube, das siehst du auf allen Plattformen, wo der unterwegs ist, dass das für den, weil du gerade jetzt auch Türkei ansprachst, ein wichtiges politisches Instrument ist zur Mobilisierung.
Aber es wird eben nicht abgestellt, so wie es zum Beispiel in der Türkei der Fall ist. Das heißt, in Twitter wird es nicht der Saft mal abgedreht.
Also ich kann natürlich nicht in die Zukunft gucken, aber aktuell ist das was, was alles toleriert wird.
Jetzt wissen wir ja, dass zu so Fußball-Events dann gerne auch mal große politische Entscheidungen durchgedrückt werden. Bei uns in Deutschland war es gleich am Anfang mal eine saftige Diätenerhöhung oder Parteienfinanzierung, wo die großen Parteien ganz komischerweise so ungefähr genau den Betrag wiederbekommen, den sie an Wähler stimmen und damit Einnahmen verloren haben. Das ging einfach so smooth durch und hat man sich auch nicht so wirklich für interessiert. Gab es denn in Russland da auch was, was im Schatten der Weltmeisterschaft durchgedrückt wurde?
Ja, gab es beziehungsweise also auf den Weg gebracht, durchgedrückt, es ist noch nicht final beschlossen, aber Erhöhung des Renteneintrittsalters. Was in Russland sowieso eine ganz andere Relevanz hat als bei uns, weil ja hier die Lebenserwartung deutlich niedriger ist. Das heißt, es gibt halt ganz klassisch einfach für mehr Leute die Frage, ob sie die eigene Verrentung erleben werden oder nicht.
Auf welches Alter wird es jetzt erhöht?
Also aktuell ist es für Männer 60 Jahre und für Frauen 55. Und das würde dann hochgehen für Männer auf 65 und für Frauen auf 63. Und die Zahl, die du halt dazu wissen musst, ist Lebenserwartung laut WHO für russische Männer 66 Jahre, für russische Frauen 77. Das heißt, die Männer hätten dann, also statistisch natürlich, ein Jahr Rente. Also Rentenalter 65, durchschnittliche Lebenserwartung 66. Das kannst du dir vorstellen, dass das für Proteste sorgt. Und das hat es auch tatsächlich getan. Man kann das gut an zwei Sachen festmachen. Erstens, es wurden Proteste angekündigt in einigen größeren Städten. Natürlich in keiner WM-Austragensstadt, weil dort ja Demonstrationsverbot ist. Während der WM. Und tatsächlich sind im Moment, obwohl du denkst, die WM ist doch so ein Boost, die Umfragewerte von Putin richtig runtergegangen. Auch bei mehreren Sachen. Also bei verschiedenen Fragen, die man da stellt, die die Meinungsforschung sich bestellen. Also sowohl vertraue ihm, als auch heiße gut, was er tut und so. Das ist alles ein ganzes Stück runtergegangen. Und es ist jetzt halt die Frage, wie sehr das sich wieder erholt. Und wenn jetzt z.B. Russland noch zwei Spiele gewinnt, ob das dann alles übertüncht oder nicht. Aber im Moment klappt es nicht so, diese Idee das mal kurz nebenbei durchzudrücken. Weil Renten sind ja einfach auch ein supersensibles Thema. Es gab vor ein paar Jahren so eine Szene, ich meine, es war auf der Krim, mit der von einer Frau angesprochen wurde, wie ist das mit den Renten? Könnten wir nicht vielleicht wenigstens einen Inflationsausgleich haben? Es muss ja gar keine Erhöhung sein. Und dann hat der sowas gesagt, das ist jetzt so ein geflügeltes Wort geworden, das kann man so übersetzen, wir haben kein Geld, aber halten sie mit mal durch.
Das ist das Russische, die Rente ist sicher, das ist ja unser geflügeltes Wort.
Und das ist halt hier total zu dem geflügelten Wort geworden. Das siehst du seitdem manchmal in Überschriften, wenn es irgendwie um fehlendes Geld führt. Wir haben kein Geld, aber halten sie durch. Das heißt, das ist halt was für das Thema, das jeder hier sensibilisiert.
Klar. Ist denn die Demografie in Russland ähnlich zu der in Deutschland? Das heißt, dass es sich immer mehr hin zu einer Rentnerrepublik entwickelt?
Na ja, also mit der Statistik ja dann nicht. Die sterben ja dann, bevor sie Rentner werden können. Ich weiß das ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so, wie das hier mit der Altersverteilung ist im Land. Das ist eigentlich eine interessante Frage. Also was ich weiß, ist, dass die Lebenserwartung, mit der wir eben sprachen, schon in den letzten Jahren gestiegen ist, dass sie aber im internationalen Vergleich immer noch relativ niedrig ist. Und dass bei Männern, also die ja wirklich, das ist das 10, 11 Jahre im Schnitt vor den Frauen sterben, halt wirklich viele tragische Faktoren zusammenkommen. Ungesunder, Lebenswandel, Krankheiten natürlich, was ja auch viel mit Verschmutzung zu tun hat, Gewaltverbrechen, Straßenverkehr, Unfälle und aber auch immer noch Alkoholismus, was einfach weiterhin eine große russische Tragödie ist, wie weit das verbreitet ist und wie viele Leute das hier betrifft.
Ja, das hab ich mir, da hab ich mich auch dran erinnert bei dem einen oder anderen Fanreporterbericht, den es gab. Ich hab einen gesehen, da hat jemand das Deutschland-Spiel gegen Mexiko, glaube ich, mit einer russischen Familie zusammen geguckt. Und das wurde dann auch eher so folkloristisch eingebaut, dass da, ich glaube, zwei oder drei Floschen Wodka getrunken wurden von diesen, dann, ich glaube, drei Männern und der Reporter musste auch annehmen. Ha, ha, ha, sehr lustig, dass ich mir auch, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, ob das jetzt die Art und Weise ist, wie man das verharmlosen muss. Aber man will ja auch nicht immer mit der Moralkeule kommen. Ich will jetzt auch nicht die ganze Zeit hier mit der Moralkeule kommen, denn das soll ja nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen, dass ja gerade die Stimmung sehr, sehr gut ist. Und so sind wir ja auch ein bisschen in diesen Podcast reingekommen. Wie hat sich denn die Wahrnehmung der russischen Nationalmannschaft eigentlich so verändert? Wir haben das letzte Mal gesprochen vor dem Eröffnungsspiel, da war das ja noch sehr vage und eher von Ironie gekennzeichnet. Und jetzt?
Total. Was ein Schwenk, oder? Und wie schnell die Leute dann auch schwenken. Vorher war es einfach komplett klar, also komplett kleines Quatsch, aber alle Leute, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, hatten so diesen, ich hoffe, aber auf keinen Fall, ich glaube dran. Und dann, nach dem ersten Sieg, was war? Saudi-Arabien.
5-0 gegen Saudi-Arabien.
Genau, 5-0 und dann hier das Ägyptenspiel. Vielleicht sagt das auch immer mein Freundeskreis aus, was die Russen angeht. Ich mag halt auch so einen gewissen Sarkasmus, und dann kriegt man ihn vielleicht auch öfter zu hören. Es waren schon viele Leute, die einfach gesagt haben, was uns das jetzt wieder gekostet hat. Was haben wir denn da wieder bezahlt? Was haben wir denn da für Deals hinter den Kulissen gemacht? Es ist natürlich null belegt. Das ist einfach so eine Art, mit einem unerwarteten Erfolg umzugehen.
Man muss auch Erfolg verarbeiten, ja klar.
Genau, genau. Aber ja, ich meine, das Spanienspiel, das kannst du eben nicht mehr so richtig erklären, mit wann eine schwache Mannschaft oder Glück gehabt bei der Vorrundenauslosung oder so. Und es heißt jetzt plötzlich große Graffiti, die Chess of Firen und Helden-Schlagzeilen. Ich habe eine Analyse gelesen über Akin Faith, also hier den Torwart, der ja wirklich beim Elfmeterschießen das mit dem Fuß gerettet hat, wo so stand, der hätte bis jetzt noch kein Turnier oder kein wichtiges Spiel gespielt, wo er nicht irgendwann mal gepatzt hätte. Und nun, also ich versuche das jetzt zu paraphrasieren, aber die Wortwahl war einfach relativ pathetisch. Und nun wissen wir endlich, warum es sein Schicksal war, an dieses Tor gekettet zu sein, damit er an diesem Tag hier steht und uns rettet. Weißt du, und ja, es ist halt, und das ist jetzt zwar keine Ionie, das ist einfach dieses Ungewohntes, dass es plötzlich läuft und diese Begeisterung, die ich da beandriche, das geht schon zum Teil echt sehr in Reston Pothos.
Aber würde es ja überall gehen, oder?
Genau, nein, nein, nein, das ist nicht spezifisch russisch. Es ist halt nur, dass ich über Russland das gerade weiß, weil ich hier bin, genau. Na, es ist einfach sehr, genau, da werden halt gerade Helden eben geboren, an Stellen, wo da echt niemand mit gerechnet hat, sondern wo die gedacht haben, alles klar, wir können schon mal die Memes basteln, für wenn Russland ausscheidet, ne?
Und merkt man das auch so im Straßenbild? Also, das ist ja kein Klischee, dass wenn bei so einem großen Turnier die Gastgebermannschaft gut abschneidet, dann ist es ja wirklich so, dass die Leute ein bisschen lockerer sind und es wird mehr gelacht, mehr Leute im Trikot sind auf der Straße. Du gibst ja, also kannst du mal mit Leuten sprechen, die jetzt in Frankfurt waren nach dem DFB-Pokalsieg. Da konntest du mit wildfremden Leuten ohne Probleme High Five austauschen und dich und einfach mal Schlag in Lang, Bruder, durch den Supermarkt brüllen. Mindestens einer hat geantwortet. Ist das so auch in Russland gerade?
Also in den Dimensionen nicht, aber wir fangen ja auch, wir erinnern uns auf einen anderen Level an. Meine Lieblingsanalogie ist ja weiterhin der Moskauer. Er ist mehr so eine Art Berliner. Also ein bisschen muffig, ein bisschen maulfoul, ein bisschen kurz angebunden. Aber es stimmt schon. Mein Eindruck in der Stadt, gerade jetzt an dem Abend natürlich nach dem Spiel, es fühlt sich etwas anders an. Mehr Blickkontakt, auch mal so irgendjemand Fremdem zu lächeln. Das ist im Moment, ich sag mal, nicht der totale Überschwank, aber so eine Leichtigkeit, die man schon jetzt mehr merkt. Das finde ich schon, ja.
Ich fand es auch sehr interessant zu sehen, wie ab einem gewissen Punkt auch in Stadien, in denen nicht Russland gespielt hat, zwischendurch mal die russische Mannschaft angefeuert wurde. Und mein Gefühl nach hat das auch wesentlich nach dem Spanienspiel angefangen.
Das ist tatsächlich immer so. Das hast du ja auch bei Liga-Spielen. Wenn jetzt irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Spartak gegen Lokomotiv spielt oder so. Ach ehrlich? Ja total, es ist vielleicht mal eine ruhige Stelle im Spiel oder, weiß ich nicht, einer Lichterverletzung wird behandelt oder man hat gerade sonst nichts zu tun, dann kommen hier Rasier-Rafia-Rufe. Das ist ein total beliebter Zeitvertrag.
Das ist ja wie das USA-USA des großen Nachbarn.
Ach das ist wieder mal, das ist so viele Parallelen zwischen Russland und den USA an so vielen Stellen. Das kannst du mal mit auf die Liste setzen, weil das ist ja dann, ich finde das im Vereinsfußball eigentlich noch viel verwunderlicher, weil sich da ja wirklich über lange Jahre verfeindete Fans plötzlich zu einem gemeinsamen Sprechchor finden.
Das kann man sich in Deutschland gar nicht vorstellen. Also davon träumt der Fanclub Nationalmannschaft.
Genau, stell dir mal vor, es ist Revier Derby und alle so schlaaaand. Aber das ist hier tatsächlich, das ist nicht von einem spannenden Spiel, sondern das ist eine Tradition, das ist üblich. Hinzu kommt glaube ich auch, es ist halt ein leicht zu lernendes Wort, das heißt auch so die ausländischen Fans steigen da ganz gerne mit ein. Rasia rufen kann halt auch jeder und es sind halt auch viele, die echt begeistert sind von der Atmosphäre hier und dann glaube ich, der schwingt so ein bisschen das Danke ans Gastgeberland mit. Aber wie gesagt, und du hörst das sogar halt bei Spielen, wo Russland nicht beteiligt ist. Also wir waren bei, wen hat, was hat, Belgien, Tunesien oder Belgien, Marokko? Jedenfalls bei den Belgien-Spielen. Belgien, Tunesien, genau. Ah ja, Portugal, Marokko, Belgien, Tunesien. Und auch da, weil natürlich so viele Leute im Stadion einfach Russen sind, dann irgendwie in der Pause oder also nicht in der Pause, eine Halbzeitpause einfach, wenn man ruhige fünf Minuten war, Rasija, Rasija, Sprechchöre, aber hallo. Super. Und ich habe auch einen neuen Sprechchor gelernt, hübschend in der Kneipe, nämlich Hey, Hey, Igor, Igor Akhentvej.
Okay, das muss man jetzt nicht mal übersetzen.
Nee, oder?
Jeder verstanden. Ach ja, irgendwie, also Akhentvej gönnt man das schon ein bisschen, so der alte Mann des russischen Fußballs. Und der letzte, der ja überlebt hat aus dieser alten Generation an Spielern, also überlebt es jetzt so drastisch, aber der jetzt noch spielen darf, während ansonsten die komplette Mannschaft ja ausgetauscht wurde, und man da wenig kannte. Was glaubst du denn jetzt, sind die Erwartungen rund um das Viertelfinale gegen Kroatien am Samstagabend, ist das immer noch so verhalten optimistisch, und dass man sich schon klar noch in der Underdog-Rolle sieht, oder könnte sich das jetzt auch drehen? Weil, der Theorie nach, sind es nur noch zwei Siege bis zum Finale, und ich würde nichts mehr ausschließen.
Und stell dir mal vor, wir haben dann Russland-England. Wie wird das denn? Also, ich glaube schon, dass viele Leute jetzt so ein bisschen die Haltung haben. Oder es ist mir ab und an begegnet, wir hätten das der Mannschaft noch mal nicht zugetraut, aber schauen wir mal, was schon ging. Und es ist eben auch der Heimvorteil, es sind unsere Fans, die uns hier anfeuern. Das ist jedem klar, dass das ein Faktor ist. Es geht jetzt nicht in Richtung, wie sagt man, Oberwasser oder so. Na klar, putzen wir die Kroaten weg. Also, das sicherlich nicht. Und du hast auch jetzt immer noch die Leute. Also, weiß ich nicht, so zum Beispiel. Es gibt hier das Gelände, auf dem wir wohnen, hat so eine Schranke zur Straße und da sitzt ein Schrankenmann. Also, da sitzen wechselnde Schrankenmänner, die diese Schranke behüten und Einlasskontrolle machen. Und da war auch einer, und jetzt am Tag vom letzten Russland-Spiel ging ich so raus in die Kneipe zum Gucken und sagte zu ihm so, ja Mensch, und viel, viel Glück ihrer Mannschaften. Und er sagt auch, ja, möge Gott es geben. Also, dieses, du kannst es letztlich nicht ändern, es wird kommen, wie es kommen wird. Und so oder so, das hat die russische Mannschaft ziemlich Unerwartetes geleistet. Und sollte das jetzt wirklich Schluss sein gegen Kroatien, dann müssen sie sich ja nicht schämen. Ja, und wenn es weitergeht, dann weiß ich gar nicht, da muss ich mal rausfinden, wo ich da spiele, dann gucke.
Dann fliegt das Dach von Russland weg. Das kann man, glaube ich, so sagen. Ich finde es total schade, dass aufgrund des Kurilischen es sehr schwierig ist, für einen selbst so Memes nachzuverfolgen und aufzuspüren. Also, gerade zu Igor Akhenfeif hast du ja auch einige in deinem Blog verarbeitet. Und ein paar hatte ich auch schon gesehen über Retweets von Journalistinnen und Journalisten, denen ich jetzt auch aufgrund deiner Empfehlungen folge. Aber das ist echt so ein bisschen schade, dass es da so eine Sprachbarriere gibt. Ansonsten glaube ich, dass das noch viel, viel weitere Kreise ziehen würde, auch in den westlichen Teilen der sozialen Netzwerke, sprachlich gesehen. Weil es einfach auch toll zu sehen ist. Also überhaupt sind Memes mit das Schönste an der Weltmeisterschaft inzwischen. Wer hätte das noch vor acht oder zwölf Jahren gedacht, aber einen Neymar sich unendlich rollend sehen oder den Titel, den brasilianischen Torhüter, den brasilianischen Trainer unendlich im Sprinten zu sehen. Und zwar sowohl in der großen Herder Ringelschlacht als auch irgendwie gegen Rocky Balboa. Wunderbar, wunderbar. Und da würden so viele von russischen Fans erstellte Memes super reinpassen, die man aber leider nicht findet, weil es andere Hashtags sind oder zu schnell aufgeschrottet.
Wobei, du kannst das ja mal in die Shownotes machen. Ich kann dir gleich mal noch einen Link schicken. Es gibt halt auch Kontakte, zu einer Seite, die wirklich nur Fußballmemes machen. Vieles ist dann einfach nur visuell. Das versteht man dann auch ohne die Frage zu verstehen. Das finde ich ganz cool. Und was mir noch neu aufgefallen ist, das war mir vorher schon mal bei so ein, zwei Vereinsspielen auf internationaler Ebene aufgefallen. Ich weiß nicht, ich hab das in Deutschland noch nicht gesehen. Vielleicht ist das da auch Usus und ich hab das mir noch nicht begegnet. Total viele Leute, die dann so zwei, drei Fotos immer wieder twittern, wo so Medizin drauf ist. Balrian, Herztabletten und so. Die siehst du eigentlich Leute jedes Mal twittern, wenn Russland spielt. Da denke ich, ich verstehe euren Humor. Ich weiß, das ist jetzt alles sehr, sehr aufregend, aber tut es nicht, lasst es noch ein bisschen stehen.
Ja, besser solche Tropfen da twittern als irgendwelche anderen Substanzen. Jetzt haben wir ja die besondere Situation, dass du als Deutsche in Russland unterwegs bist und ja auch als Fan der deutschen Nationalmannschaft ein Spiel besucht hast auf dem Fanfest. Wie war denn das so für dich?
Ah, du meinst das auf dem Fanfest oder das Spiel, wo ich wirklich im Stadion war?
Stimmt, genau, du warst ja einmal auf dem Fanfest und einmal im Stadion, richtig, erinnere mich.
Also zum Schwedenfest waren wir hier mit einer ganzen Gruppe, äh Schwedenfest, Schwedenspiel.
Na gut, am Ende war es ein Fest.
Ein einziges. Waren wir hier oben in den Sperlingsbergen vor der Uni auf dem Fanfest mit so einer Gruppe von Leuten.
Ab die Studierenden am Lernengehen.
Ich weiß und ich habe mich auch wirklich geschämt. Also so 30% oder so. Es ist so eine Mischung. Einerseits natürlich, ob du alleine hingehst oder nicht, macht keinen Unterschied. Andererseits, wenn das jeder so sieht, verändert sich nie was. Nur in diesem Fall ist das Fanfest nun halt wirklich ein Fakt, der sich nicht mehr ändern wird. Jedenfalls. Also wenn ich nicht mit Zittern und Sorge beschäftigt war, hatte ich schon mal ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Ich wollte dir kein schlechtes Gewissen jetzt anreden.
Zu spät, das habe ich selber. Vielen Dank. Aber du bist sowieso gar nicht so viel zu reflektieren gekommen, weil halt so, also wir waren halt als deutsche Fans erkennbar, weiß nicht, Blumengelande, Trikots, Fahne. Und wie viele Leute da kamen und sagten, ah ja, und hier, und Deutschland schafft das. Und ich war immer so, ich war immer so, die deutsche Maschine, sagt man dann auf Russland immer, auf Russisch immer, die deutsche Maschine wird das alles schaffen. Und dann ein Foto machen wollten mit uns. Oder mit der Fahne. Oder in der Falle von zwei Frauen auch mal, nee, nee, ohne euch, wir wollen nur eure Fahne. Was gibt ihr auch besonders für einen Fall?
Ist das nicht total merkwürdig, wenn ein Fremde Menschen fotografieren wollen? Für sich?
Ja, und ich finde es okay, wenn sie mit aufs Foto wollen. Aber wenn man so das Spektakel ist, und man soll nur mal schnell posieren für ein Foto, da ist es in der Tat, das ist mir ein bisschen zu nah am Zoo. Aber gut, dann stellt man sich hin und stellt sich in die 2, 3 und guckt zum Boden und dann hat man irgendwie die Geste mitgemacht und muss trotzdem jetzt nicht auf deren Instagram-Account erscheinen. Das ist ja nicht der Moment, wo du sowas ausverhandelst. Und im Paar, also alles mal, zum Beispiel nach dem Spiel gegen Südkorea, da können wir gleich noch drüber reden, kam auch jemand, da haben wir dann auch gesagt, du, uns ist jetzt gerade nicht nach Fotos, und dann war das auch überhaupt kein Problem, das ist jetzt nicht so, dass die Leute insistieren. Ja gut, und ich meine, dass das Spiel gegen Schweden ein einziges Leiden war bis zu diesem Schlussmoment, muss man ja heute wirklich nicht mehr thematisieren. Aber, es war, wie gesagt, das, was mir am einprägsamsten war von der ganzen Zeit, ist, wie viele Leute irgendwie kamen, einem zugesprochen haben. Da stellte sich plötzlich, wir standen da so in der Gruppe, plötzlich stand eine hinter uns und brüllte immer der deutschen Mannschaft auf Russisch irgendwelche Sachen zu, die auch stimmten. Also mehr weiß ich nicht, ihr müsst mehr über links gehen oder jetzt musst du schießen. Nicht nochmal passen, weißt du? Dann kam wir so ein bisschen ins Gespräch und sie ist Russin, unterstützt die deutschen Nationalmannschaften. Die hat sich dann einfach zu uns gestellt und es war total nett und gesellig, weißt du? Das sind ja immer so die guten Momente, wenn du dich irgendwie verbrüderst da. Das muss ja auch gar nicht immer die große Geste sein. Da reicht ja schon irgendwie zusammenstehen, zusammen anfeuern. Ja, das war schön. Das war auch ganz praktisch von da oben, von dem Fanfest fährt so ein Shuttlebus bis zum Kiewer Bahnhof. Und da in der Nähe wohne ich. Das heißt dann irgendwie mit dem Shuttle runtergezuckelt, wo alle Leute am Singen waren. Das waren total schöne, so sommerliche Momente halt.
Und schöne russische Lieder gesungen. Nicht irgendwie Fan-Gesänge oder Schlachtrufe, sondern das hatte richtig Melodie und Charme.
Total. Also ganz am Anfang irgendwas Mexikanisches, weil da ein paar Jungs mit Sombreros im Bus waren. Aber dann haben die Russen das über den Norman. Natürlich, wo sind im Moment keine. Ich meine jetzt nicht mehr, aber wo waren in dem Zeitpunkt keine Leute mit Sombreros. Aber dann genau, also so Sachen, das große sentimentale Russland-Repertoire, das Gegenstück zum Great American Songbook, wenn wir in Amerika-Analogien bleiben. Naja, und das Südkoreaspiel in Kazan war einfach scheiße und schmerzhaft, weil wir hatten Echtplätze in der fünften Reihe. Wir saßen direkt hinterm Tor. Wir haben versucht, diesen Ball da reinzubrüllen. Und das hat leider überhaupt nicht geholfen, wie er bekannt ist. Vor uns haben sich die ganzen Leute warmgemacht, die da gleich reingehen sollten. Es war auch ein ganz interessanter Blog, weil wir haben die Tickets ja, also wir waren nicht im Fan-Blog, wir hatten die nicht über den DFB gekauft, sondern ganz normal über das FIBA-Portal. Das heißt, hinter uns oder rechts von uns saß so ein Typ aus Kasachstan, ziemlicher Assi, der irgendwie so allen auf die Füße trat beim Durchgehen und zu seiner Frau sich irgendwie motzig verhielt. Und die Frau war halt mit Deutschland-Fähnchen, Deutschland-Hut. Und am Ende total in Tränen und eher so yeah, yeah, Südkorea. Also ich hab gedacht, Scheppe, vielleicht kannst du doch einen besseren finden. Naja, also so einer, aber halt auch ganz viele Leute aus irgendwelchen Ländern, die ja für Deutschland gejubelt haben. Und auch so Leute, wo du merkst, dass eben für die Fußball, Schlachtrufe, Anfeuern gar nicht so alltäglich sind. Und dass das vielleicht eine erste Erfahrung ist. Das heißt, hinter uns saß eine, die wusste gar nicht, was sie rufen sollte. Die hat dann immer die Namen genommen von irgendwelchen koreanischen Spielern und einfach jetzt hinterhergerufen so, Lee, jetzt. Weißt du so? Also ich verstehe total, was sie meint. Aber du merkst halt auch, das ist neu für die und irgendwie aufregend. Das muss jetzt raus. Und die hat nicht irgendwie die festen Sprechbeköre im Kopf. Also als Erfahrung war das weiterhin natürlich interessant. Aber das Ende war halt kacke natürlich. Und du hast ja auch nichts, worüber du dich ärgern kannst. Du kannst nicht sagen, wir sind schlecht behandelt worden. Du kannst nicht sagen, ach, weißt du, hätten wir den in der Minute reingemacht, dann wäre das anders gegangen. Kannst du nicht?
Oder der Viertrichter war schuld.
Genau. Nee, es war einfach ein richtig schwaches Spiel. Und es war nicht das erste schwache Spiel. Und da kann man sich nicht beschweren. Da kann man traurig sein. Das war ich nun auch echt und deprimiert und so. Ich hätte gerne hier noch ein bisschen gefeiert. Aber ich meine, was ist die Alternative dir wünschen, dass du irgendwie mit Glück oder einer ungerechten Schiri-Entscheidung weiterkommst? Das kann es ja auch nicht sein. Und ja, wir hatten so ein Airbnb. Ich mag Kazan sowieso. Ich bin da ein bisschen parteiisch. Das ist eine tolle Stadt. Ich war da schon ein paar Mal im Winter. Jetzt habe ich sie zum ersten Mal im Sommer erlebt. Das ist möglicherweise noch schöner, weil sie am Wasser liegt. Wir hatten so ein Airbnb, ein Stück raus aus dem Zentrum. Klassischer sowjetischer Wohnblock. Fünf Etagen oder Aufzug.
Geht das jetzt doch mit Airbnb? Ich dachte, wir hätten uns mal drüber unterhalten, dass es ein bisschen schwierig wäre.
Nee, nee, das bezog sich nicht nur auf Moskau. Sonst bezieht es sich auf die Registrierung. Du musst dich ja eigentlich registrieren, wenn du hier im Land bist. Und das macht noch einen Kells für dich. Und da brauchst du einen Vermieter. Das gilt aber erst ab drei Tagen. Insofern, aber weißt du, super netter Vermieter, der Sohn hat uns mit einem Kumpel vom Flughafen im Auto abgeholt, nur damit sie ein bisschen in Englisch üben können. Und zwar alles so ein bisschen brachial in der Verstelligung, aber viel Hahaha, bloß ich und eure Mannschaft und unsere Mannschaft. Und als wir dann ausgecheckt haben, irgendwann nachmittags, war der eigentliche Vermieter mit seiner Frau, den kannten wir bis dahin noch nicht, und waren irgendwie schon, hallo, wie war es in der Küche und Werke? Dann sprachen wir noch ein bisschen, und der Mann sagte, ich kann das überhaupt nicht verstehen, ihr seid doch der amtierende Weltmeister, und ihr habt doch letztes Jahr beim Konfett Cup noch so ordentlich gespielt hier in Russland, was denn da passiert? Und die Frau auch so, ja, und dann sagt sie, ja, aber hier, wir haben euch jetzt mal hier so Gurken bei uns aus dem Garten mitgebracht, und die sind auch nicht gespritzt, die sind total gesund, und die könnt ihr einfach essen, und dann nehmt ihr die mit nach Moskau, und dann denkt ihr an Kazan. Und dann so, wir werden jetzt nicht Gurken als erstes Mittel des Trostes eingefallen, wenn die eigene Nationalmannschaft bei der WM rausfliegt.
Also waren es denn elf Gurken, hast du mal nachgezählt, dann hat sie dich ganz subtil beleidigt.
Hätte ich mal, glaube ich nicht, vor allem, es war noch einige Krumme dabei. Also die eine war vielleicht eine Metapher auf diesen wunderschönen Groß, dieses wunderschöne Groß-Tour. Nein, es war einfach, weißt du, es wäre mir überhaupt nicht eingefallen, aber ich fand das tatsächlich irgendwie süß und tröstlich im vernünftigen Rahmen. Wir haben dann irgendwie eine Tüte Gurken mit hier nach Moskau zurückgeflogen und hier als Salat gegessen. Und wenn die letzte Gurke gegessen ist, wird auch der Schmerz schon etwas geringer sein.
Katrin, das alles hört sich so ein bisschen an, als sollte die WM nie aufhören. Es wird sicher auch gut für die Infrastruktur in Russland. Eine meiner Lieblingsgeschichten, die ich auch bei dir entdeckt habe, war das Fanschlagloch in Nischni. Ein Schlagloch, das so groß ist, dass sich Fans darin fotografieren lassen, was dann dazu führt, dass dieses Schlagloch sehr schnell auf einmal zugeteert ist über Nacht.
Also, wenn jetzt jemand sagen würde, weiß ich nicht, wir müssen eine Woche länger machen, weil, fände ich das total okay. Auf Dauer ist es natürlich schon auch irgendwann schön, wenn nicht jeden Tag du gucken musst, kann ich heute auf den roten Platz oder ist da irgendwas abgesperrt. Aber ich finde, für so einen begrenzten Zeitraum ist das ja was, was man total gerne in kaufen will.
Genau, und jetzt sind es ja auch nur noch acht Spiele. Das ist ja das Erschreckende.
Auf allen Dingen natürlich noch weniger in Spieltagen, wegen Doppelspiel pro Tag.
Genau, genau. Also jetzt noch am Freitag, am Samstag und dann noch unter der Woche, nächste Woche. Und dann werden wir schon uns ein Spiel um Platz drei angucken, bei dem wir uns fragen wollen, warum gucken wir das eigentlich? Und dann werden wir uns ein Finale angucken.
Das Spiel um Platz drei gucken wir, weil das ein schönes Stadion ist in Petersburg. Wir möchten ja einfach das Stadion sehen.
Ja, das stimmt. Wobei gerade das Stadion in St. Petersburg mit seinen horrenden Baukosten, die in die Milliarden geschätzt werden, wo ja auch einiges, also wenn man sich da drüber mal ein bisschen recherchiert, dann ist das so.
Ja, großer Korruptionstempfe.
Ja, ja, Wahnsinn. Deswegen, ja, ich finde das auch wunderschön, aber ich konnte mich nie von dem Gedanken lösen, dass ich mir gedacht habe, dass es jetzt auch wieder so, also es ist kein kompletter weißer Elefant, weil es gibt wenigstens einen Club vor Ort, der diese Stadion verwenden kann, nämlich Zenith, das ist auch ein großer Verein, aber es ist auch so eine klassische FIFA-WM-Geschichte. Also nicht, dass da jetzt die FIFA alleine fliegt zu.
Ich wollte sagen, es ist FIFA trifft Russland und von beiden das Schlechteste findet sich in dem Fall zusammen. Aber, hör mal, das einzige Stadion, das einen eigenen Twitter-Account für sein Dach hat.
Okay, gut, jetzt hast du mich. Ich finde das Stadion auch toll. Und ich bin wirklich nicht leicht zu beeindrucken. Aber ein Twitter-Account für das Dach...
Heute bin ich offen, heute bin ich zu.
Ach, Wahnsinn, Twitter. Es ist einfach ein tolles Netzwerk. Katrin, das hat mir wieder sehr, sehr großen Spaß gemacht, mit dir zu sprechen. Und ich finde es wirklich...
Ja, mein Schmack, das fand ich auch.
Toll, wie sich das alles so ein bisschen verändert hat. Also, wir reden jetzt schon so häufig miteinander. Ich habe so viel gelernt über Russland, die Hörerinnen und Hörer auch. Daher kommt deine große Fanshaw. Und jetzt auch zu hören, dass es so viele schöne, positive Geschichten gibt. Das ist einfach schön zu hören. Und jetzt kannst du es noch anderthalb Wochen genießen, bis der Spuk dann vorbei ist.
Das wirkliche Problem ist, dass jetzt hier am Samstag ein Freund der Moskau verlässt seine Abschiedsparty. Und ich jetzt schon versuche, so dezente Nachrichten zu schicken. Und der sich nicht für Fußball interessiert. Wenn ich jetzt ständig Nachrichten schicke... Also, ihr habt ja da in eurer Wohnung zwei Zimmer. Und vielleicht kann man ja einen ein... Also, ich würde auch mein iPad mitbringen. Ja, muss ich mal schauen.
Naja, also wenn sogar die Balletttänzerin im Bolschoi-Theater in ihrer Ballettpause das russische Spiel gucken...
Ja, und lustigerweise ist das hier sogar ein Balletttänzer-Freund. Das stimmt, so werde ich dem nämlich kommen.
Also, das muss er aber auch verstehen. Also, Samstag, 20 Uhr abends, also bei euch dann Ortszeit 21 Uhr. Da wird nichts mehr gehen. In Russland ist auch völlig okay. Dann geht es gegen Kroatien. Und ich bin total gespannt auf dieses Spiel überhaupt. Ich muss sagen, diese WM, klar aus deutscher Sicht enttäuschend. Und da wird auch noch viel drüber zu reden sein. Und da war auch wirklich sehr, sehr viel ziemlich schlecht. Und die Spiele erhauen einen auch nicht immer vom Hocker, aber so von der gesamten Melange an Überraschungen, an dem Mix an Teams, die wir jetzt in den Viertelfinals sehen, ist das der Hammer. Also, wenn ich überlege, morgen werden wir Uruguay, Frankreich, Brasilien, Belgien erleben. Also, bitte, Leute.
Es gibt so viele richtig spannende Spiele. Ich meine, das England-Spiel zum Beispiel, das war ja nicht gut, aber am Schluss halt spannend. Oder habe ich das falsch gesehen?
Wie viele Tore auch wir in der Nachspielzeit hatten. Ich meine, klar, vom Fußball her ist es nicht der Atemberaubende. Aber das ist halt leider gerade so die Entwicklung des Fußballs. Das wird hoffentlich wieder besser werden. Ich hätte es mir, vielleicht bin ich deswegen auch ein bisschen zu positiv gegenüber dieser WM eingestellt. Haben mir manche Leute auch schon vorgeworfen. Mit dem Vorwissen der EM 2016 habe ich echt das Schlimmste erwartet. Ich dachte, dass wir die Fünfer- und zum Teil Sechserketten, die wir bei der EM gesehen haben, bei der WM viel häufiger sehen. Das gibt es aber ganz selten. Und vor allem, wenn es Fünferketten gibt, dann sehr offensiv Ausgerichtete bei Belgien und England. Panama nehme ich jetzt mal raus. Wir hatten eine Sechserkette, das war Tunesien und der Iran, Entschuldigung, nicht Tunesien, Tunesien war eine Fünferkette, der Iran gegen Portugal und gegen Spanien und Panama, Panama hat zum Teil eine Neunerkette gespielt, also das kann man nicht zählen. Aber das war es schon. Ansonsten haben das eigentlich alle ähnlich gemacht, alle gegen den Ball in einem 4-4-2. Und jetzt müssen sich halt die Mannschaften bitte Lösungen dafür überlegen, dann wird die nächste WM auch noch ein bisschen toller. Aber so ist halt gerade der Fußball.
Du hast halt einfach so viele Momente, wo du jetzt gerade auch so hier im Freundeskreis, na, hast du das Spiel gesehen? Ach, wo wart ihr denn als Dust-Tor viel? Wirklich so was, ne? Also hier das Frankreichsspiel, wir waren in so einer Kellerkneipe, ähm, also Markus, mein Mann und ich, und noch ein Freund, der aus Deutschland da war. Und der Freund ging kurz raus, ruft seine Frau an, kommt wieder rein, zwei Tore mehr. Weißt du so. Und schöne Tore auch noch.
Also das war sowieso, dieses Frankreichsspiel. Da war ich mit den Kindern auf einer Feier, und wenn ich mit den Kindern unterwegs bin, dann Handy aus und so weiter, nichts mitbekomme. Irgendwann sagt einer auf der Feier so, ach ja, Spiel ist übrigens vorbei, 4 zu 3. Und ich so, krass, ist ins Elfmeterschießen gegangen. Er so, nee, nee, 4 zu 3. Und dann hab ich nachts im Reallife geguckt, und ich muss sagen, selten ist es mir so einfach gefahren, ein Spiel im Reallife zu gucken, was einfach so schön war.
Da war es doch überhaupt nicht schlimm, dass ich das Ergebnis schon wusste.
Ja, sehr, sehr gut. Und von solchen Geschichten gibt es ganz, ganz viele. Katrin, wir sollten, also wir werden definitiv noch weiter im Rasenfunk sprechen. Was ich dich noch fragen wollte, dein Newsletter mit all den Geschichten, die du so sammelst, rund um die Fußball-WM in Russland, wird da eigentlich weitergehen? Oder welche Pläne hast du damit?
Oh man, das ist, das ist, ehrlich gesagt, können wir das crowdsourcen, weil ich hab's noch nicht entschieden und das hören doch jetzt so viele Leute. Also das eine ist, also so ein, zwei Wochen nach der WM, finde ich, kann das gut noch ein wöchentlicher Newsletter sein, weil du dann noch sehr viele akute Geschichten haben wirst, irgendwelche Nachwehen und Stadien umbauten, da wird's bestimmt noch viel Interessantes zu erzählen geben. Dann, ich hatte überlegt, ist danach vielleicht nur noch so in größeren Intervallen mal zu machen, weiß ich nicht. Nach einem Vierteljahr mal zurückblicken. Oder wenn die russische Nationalmannschaft ihr nächstes Länderspiel hat oder so. Denn da sind so zwei Sachen, die für mich konkurrieren. Das eine ist, ich möchte auf gar keinen Fall irgendwen zuspammen, das hasse ich selber. Andererseits denke ich, das sind nun Leute, die haben das abonniert, weil die sich vielleicht nicht nur bis zur WM interessieren. Das heißt, ich habe auch überlegt, ob ich irgendwie am Ende vom nächsten Newsletter mal eine Umfrage mache. Das ist doch super, die Millionen von Menschen, die Rasenfunk hören, können mir auch mal sagen, was ich machen soll damit. Ich bin noch so ein bisschen unschlüssig. Ich habe total Bock, nicht mehr zwingend auf wöchentlich. Ich finde es schon schön, wenn ich mal in Dienstag Abend wieder zur Chorprobe gehen kann, statt statt links zusammen zu dengeln. Aber grundsätzlich macht das Thema weiter Spaß. Es ist weiter interessant. Jetzt kommen ja die ganzen Geschichten. Was macht es denn mit dem Land? Macht es was mit dem Land? Im Moment tendiere ich zu weitermachen, aber in größeren Intervallen.
Finde ich, hört sich prima an. Ich finde, die Hörerinnen und Hörer sollten sich bei dir melden. Entweder bei uns im Forum, da ist der Link, auf der Seite zu finden, oder dich einfach anschreiben. Auf Twitter, et.k.scheib heißt du dort. Dann können wir mal ein Stimmungsbild uns zusammen basteln. Ich kann dir schon verraten, ich habe ernsthaft schon angefangen, zu recherchieren, ob ich irgendjemanden aus anderen Ländern finden könnte, der ähnliche Dinge mit mir machen könnte. Weil ich das einfach so spannend finde, mal ein Land näher kennenzulernen in Fußballsachen. Ob es da auch einen portugiesischen Fan gibt, da passieren ja auch gerade die wildesten Dinge mit Sporting. Da hat man gerade gar keine Zeit für in der Berichterstattung. Und ich habe auch schon gesucht, gibt es irgendjemanden aus Katar oder aus einem Anrainerstaat, der die dortige Presse kennt. Aber ich bin noch nicht fünnig geworden. Also wenn jemand draußen einen Tipp hat für jemanden, der des Englischen mächtig ist und mit dem man vielleicht hin und wieder mal sprechen könnte, der einem eben einfach die Presseberichte und so weiter, die es gibt, mitverfolgt und ein bisschen einen aufklären kann und das Bild vervollständigen kann, rund um Katar, da hätte ich großes Interesse dran. Ich glaube, das wäre auch für den Rasenfunk toll.
Ja, du hörst mich nicken, das fände ich auch gut.
Sehr gut, dann gibt es bald auch die Neuigkeiten aus Katar hier im Rasenfunk. Katrin, das war der längste Kurzpass, glaube ich, bei dieser WM. Aber womit? Mit 100-prozentigem Recht.
Der Langpass.
Der Langpass. Der lange Ball, das passt ja auch irgendwie zum russischen Spiel. Da war ja auch durchaus mal der lange Ball auf Juba mit dabei. Und du warst jetzt hier in diesem Szenario mein Juba. Das ist natürlich nur als Kompliment.
Da musst du jetzt salutieren, ist klar.
Das habe ich auch gerade gemacht, was denkst du? Katrin, vielen herzlichen Dank dir, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst.
Ja, danke für die Einladung.
Ja, wir werden das nochmal wiederholen. Du wirst mir nicht davonkommen. Wir müssen noch weiter über Russland sprechen. Ich finde das so interessant. Danke dir. Sehr schön. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke fürs Zuhören. Meldet euch bei Katrin. Meldet euch im Forum. Ich bin sehr gespannt auf euer Feedback. Morgen gibt es natürlich den nächsten Kurzpass. Und ich werde auch ein Tribügengespräch produzieren rund um ein Thema bei dieser Fußball-WM. Das erscheint, na ja, wenn alles nach Plan verläuft, entweder morgen Nachmittag oder am Wochenende. Drückt mir die Daumen, dass das alles klappt. Ihr könnt uns unterstützen auf rasenfunk.de/unterstützen. Und dann hören wir uns morgen wieder. Macht's gut, ciao!